Trump the name is synonymous with
quality luxury being better than losers
and class it's been on golf courses
casinos and beautiful meat now I'm
lending my name to the failing game show
at midnight and they need it they need
it tremendously I've bought and paid for
every episode this week just like I
bought and paid for my beautiful wife
Melania and soft little nougat
chinchilla Chrissy Hardwick is going to
play the games I want to play it's going
to be huge
stupendous the bestest okay you losers
here's more than you deserve
Trump presents @midnight and now it's
time for tonight's hashtag Wars
tonight's sponsor Donald Trump has a
very interesting grasp on the English
language if he wasn't sponsoring the
show I'd say the D rambles like a
toddler on bath salts but he is so I
can't it's an order celebrate 2016 s
most innovative orator tonight's hashtag
is trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
okay stop talking we Willie Seacrest I
paid for this episode and I'm gonna play
in this segment because no one is better
at quoting me than me
I am tremendous I'm incredible at it I'm
incredible chip also all my answers are
worth eight times the points of everyone
else got it
we got a Chuck I don't I feel dirty we
should have your daughter bathe you at
night
I don't really a have a daughter tonight
[Applause]
Kenny all right all right tonight's
tonight's hashtag it's Trump a quote
examples might be all the world's a
stage and all the men and women are
merely losers I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock begin
Doug Benson I see dead people all right
fine Katie sack up life is like a box of
chocolates that's fun to steal from poor
people all right points the tusks in
Spain excuse me forget it Jake China
down oh it's China
duh all right yeah I have million points
fine fine fine
Natasha you can't judge a book by its
ghostwriter all right boys
good
Doug Benson excuse me grace excuse
doctor get what that's not what you can
do for your country
ask how you can my daughter out all
right I cannot give you points for that
and ever sleep soundly again Doug Benson
we're gonna need a bigger vote all right
fine well good Haidee sack up what is
wrong step for man and two small hands
for me all right points excuse me Doug
buzz in excuse me what call me Ishmael
but that does sound like a Muslim name
so maybe we should take me out of the
country
all right Jesus Christ I am I'm doing a
damn good about I said oh uh Doug Benson
Luke people are saying I'm your father I
don't know if it's true but that's what
people have been saying all right guys
early on
mr. Gorbachev keeps the wall intact all
right boys Doug Benson phone home
I know you're an illegal alien your
fingers are longer than mine you gotta
go
excuse me excuse me excuse me what
excuse me what what excuse me okay am I
my brother's keeper
of course I am he's locked up and get my
with everybody else all right uh-huh
yes points points with that Natasha I
love the smell of spray tan in the
morning all right
touch your face it's so right fat it's
made out of stress ball material that
brings to the end of hashtagwars you can
send us your hashtag Trump a quote and
tag those @midnight to keep the game
going Oh nightmare huh hey what yeah
pneumonia she has polio I don't know
what this guy's problem is I'm winning
I'm winning everyone else I'm really
sorry we don't know when he's gonna turn
up for the rest of the week so please
just bear with us we're trying to keep
the lights on here we'll be right back
with more @midnight
[Applause]
our tweet-of-the-day from our last
hashtag war was sent to us by a trio
Donald